Amy Goodman trying to remember the first
time you came to this table when no one
even could spell it let alone know what
it's about and it's all over the papers
this morning and has been for the last
couple weeks reparation of East Timor
EES may begin this week UN says are you
learning anything about this story you
didn't know when you was first time you
went there 1990 so it's been almost a
decade why do we now know all about this
we know about this because on August
30th there was a historic referendum
that took place in East Timor which was
occupied by Indonesia beginning in 1975
one of the worst genocides of the 20th
century proportionately larger than what
happened in Pol Pot's Cambodia I think
the reason we haven't known about it all
these years is the difference between
Pol Pot and Indonesia which was occupied
Timor is that Pol Pot was an enemy of
the United States Indonesia long an ally
of the United States and so what has
happened in Timor is partially the
responsibility of the United States
here's a map from the Christian Science
Monitor and you can see Indonesia which
has a couple hundred million two hundred
million people there but we're talking
about Timor and this is only East Timor
how many people live there in East Timor
it's about 800,000 but a third of the
population has been killed 200,000
people why why killed the Indonesian
military invaded in 1975 closed the
country to the outside world and started
exterminating the population 90% of the
weapons used were from the United States
the Tim Rees would not accept an
annexation by Indonesia Indonesia never
had a claim on Timor and so as the
people resisted Indonesia just kept on
killing until finally last year
Indonesian students and workers took to
the streets this in Indonesia the fourth
largest country in the world and they
ousted the longest reigning dictator in
the world Suharto Habibi came to power
and because of tremendous international
pressure and because repression is
expensive cost about a million dollars a
day to occupy his Timor he said he would
allow a referendum and so this past
summer on August 30th that is exactly
what happened all hundreds of thousands
of Tim Ruiz went to the polls and they
voted overwhelmingly for independence
that's the thing
part of the story the historic moment
what's horrendous about what happened is
right after this referendum the
Indonesian military and its militias in
East Timor rampage through the country
basically destroying it burning it to
the ground and what is also outrageous
about this for u.s. citizens is that the
militia said they would do this that
they would commit a bloodbath against
the people of Timor if they voted for
independence and unfortunately President
Clinton though the warnings were there
all along did not cave to pressure at
the beginning to cut off the military
relationship with Indonesia to cut off
World Bank and IMF loans until finally
after the killings after the country was
burned President Clinton at the APEC
summit in Auckland New Zealand announced
precisely that that the military
relations would be cut military weapon
sales stopped World Bank and IMF loan
stopped and as soon as he did that
Britain announced that weapon sales
would be cut to Indonesia and then
finally the Indonesian military caved
and allowed in a peacekeeping we have a
lot to talk about other issues our fair
game here for Amy Goodman who hosts her
own radio show on Pacifica Radio every
day at what time 9:00 in the morning
although it can air at different times
around the country good acting in New
York on our moderate line good morning
you're on the air and that great that
show is called Democracy Now and it's a
great show and one thing I was trying to
understand about Democracy Now and Amy
Goodman is the lack of understanding
that she brings regarding the American
Constitution specifically the Second
Amendment it's obvious that had the east
to Murray's been armed that they could
have prevented the bloodbath and killed
over 300,000 ista Marines before yet yet
as far as her support of the Second
Amendment here in the United States to
prevent the government of the United
States from ever getting out of hand
it is completely non-existent so I don't
understand it and I'd like to have an
explanation Thanks
actually there was a small guerrilla
group in East Timor who were in the
mountains they had pretty primitive arms
but no matter what they could not have
prevented the bloodshed because you're
talking about a tiny country versus the
world's fourth largest population that
is Indonesia and that country Indonesia
was armed by the most powerful country
in the world the United States by the
way I do want to say that right now in
Congress there are bills up that could
be voted on this week there are two
bills that are absolutely critical
because while President Clinton has cut
off the weapons sales has cut off the
military relationship with Indonesia for
the time being what senator russell
Feingold who is the Wisconsin Democrat
has put forward and Patrick Kennedy of
Rhode Island in the house our bills that
would continue the halting of those
weapons sales the military aid the World
Bank and the IMF funds until a number of
conditions are met I just wanted to say
what those bills are because they are so
significant the Senate bill is Senate
bill one five six eight and the House
bill is HR 28 95 right now the House
bill is being held up in the
International Relations Committee Kohl's
make a tremendous difference on an issue
where people really do matter in this
country Tim Murray's no more than the
United States when a bill passes in the
United States because they know the
difference in their Amy Goodman of
Pacifica Radio Buffalo New York you're
next you mentioned something earlier in
I think when you first came on regarding
the media coverage the minimal media
coverage of the goings-on in East Timor
primarily because Indonesia is or we
have diplomatic relations or we're
friends with Indonesia and I don't quite
understand the connection I also want to
mention that about a year ago I happen
to be surfing on the web and I came
across the website that chronicled in
text and pictures
some horrible goings-on in Jakarta I
think it was where the the soldiers were
murdering and systematically raping and
brutalizing ethnic Chinese women I have
not heard anything about this in the
major media so I guess my question is
what does the fact that we have friendly
relations or diplomatic relations have
to do with the news coverage since the
media aren't controlled by the United
States why is it that we hear very
little about certain things based on our
diplomatic relations with that country
country I think it's a good question and
I do think that unfortunately the
corporate media in this country very
much follows the Washington agenda I
mean you look at the story of teamwork
in 75 Indonesia invaded East Timor in
the next year's that was the height of
the killing thousands to tens of
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
temari's killed and yet in those ensuing
years and 76 and 77 the number of column
inches devoted to the genocide and Timor
for example in the New York Times came
down to zero the from 1975 when
Indonesia invaded to 1991 when the
Indonesian military committed massacre
and Timor that the world came to know
about because Western journalists there
I was there with another journalist
named Alan Aaron and there were a few
other journalists there and 252 Marie's
were gunned down with US weapons and
that's 17-year period NBC CBS or ABC
never mentioned the words East Timor
unfortunately why you don't have that
kind of direct control which is
fortunate I think for example that you
had in the old Soviet Union you have
media that very much follows the
Washington agenda so you didn't have
presidents Ford and corridor Reagan Bush
and Clinton speaking out against
Indonesia because it was an ally and so
rarely did you have the media pursuing
the story independently and only
recently have we gotten some of the
coverage that should have been there all
of these years speaking of the media
this is a very small item at the bottom
of Howard Kurtz's mundi column speaking
of affairs he says New York Post gossip
Cindy Adams
says she knew three months ago that NB
seize her Aldo Rivera was leaving his
wife Cici for a twenty-something woman
she writes that she didn't report it
because quote Geraldo's my friend and
that she would never break a story that
breaks up a couple with children San
Francisco California next for Amy
Goodman Brian and Amy I'm so glad that
this is it goes back on the air I have
one question with the thing I'd like to
talk about is going back to the health
insurance issue we are supposedly you
know the most powerful most you know
wealthy nation in the world yet we are
the only industrialized nation without
national health care and there are a lot
of people who can't get health care okay
I'll give you an example I am I was a
bartender here my back come to the 80s
and the early 90s I had I was after
paying insurance for many years to I
forgot the name of the company they
simply dropped us because we were in
like a red zone you know they they just
drop this there was nothing you know and
you can't get back and when you're
forced on to disability I mean you're
not really allowed to work or to make
any money and so you're basically forced
into a type of poverty you're not
allowed to try to take part and you know
this ever expanding economy thanks color
it's a very important point and it goes
to one of the top stories today and that
is report that's just out that shows
that the number of Americans who lack
health insurance to continue to increase
last year
climbing to forty four point three
million in spite of a prosperous economy
and recent government efforts to expand
coverage I'm reading that piece from the
Washington Post and I think it's a front
pager on a number in a number of
newspapers today and it's very important
to point out that
the media talks about the Dow Jones
going up and celebrates a prosperous
economy that in fact one in six people
in this country or without coverage and
that is absolutely really a sin when you
look at how wealthy this country is and
today in the House of Representatives
this week will be the debates on health
care also you see the debate going on
the democratic party with Bill Bradley
proposing universal health care to cover
the poorest of US citizens and well gore
is trying to deal with it David Horowitz
will be here in about 30 minutes and he
has this little booklet among other
things the art of political war and that
sells for about 395 and he's got some
things in here he says about the media
will read it in just a moment but
Sterling Virginia is on the line
conservative car for Amy Goodman good
morning good morning how are you Brian
how are you Amy hi good I'll tell you
what I would like to do is on the front
page of The Washington Times there's an
article and it talks about firms still
living with more toxic aftermath now
what I would like to discuss with you is
the conduct of our NATO pilots that
devastated a sovereign nation and what
amazes me is that we violated we turned
a NATO defensive agreement into an
offensive offensive agreement now
reuters reported that NATO missile to
the bridge in central Serbia which was
crowded with traffic and pedestrians on
a busy Sunday afternoon the NATO pilots
decapitated the priest and killed many
of the people that were walking on the
bridge but what was worse was the answer
people ran to help these these victims
the NATO pilot went back and hit the
bridge again we know that CNN has
pictures of decapitated Serbian children
the destruction that we hit with the oil
refineries and yet we talk about Easter
Indonesia when our own pilots were being
as far as I'm concerned war criminals in
this aspect also what is your comment on
that well I also disagreed very much
with the bombing of Yugoslavia in the
end it's a civilians that get hurt and
that's just what you're describing the
pictures that you're laying out looking
at the Washington Times says Serbs still
living with wars toxic a thorough
aftermath it's from Pan chavo Yugoslavia
the Serbian fishermen looked dolefully
at 20 catfish he and his son had netted
it should have been a welcome hole given
the scarcity of meat and fish after
NATO's bombing campaign last spring if
not for the tons of liquid mercury
spilled into the river by NATO bombs yes
it's a very serious issue war is toxic
for people and for the environment and
there are alternatives and I think
certainly in the case of Yugoslavia
bombing was not the answer as I showed
you earlier this little booklet to be
interested in hearing Amy Goodman
talking about the media here is somebody
on the other side of the political fence
David Horowitz who writes in this little
pamphlet the Republican Party claims to
be the party of personal responsibility
it has become a party that takes no
responsibility for the predicaments it
finds itself in instead of Republicans
blame bias in the media or the liar in
the White House or their unprincipled
opponents or even the immorality of the
American people to explain their defeats
how can you win in American politics if
you have contempt for the judgment of
the American people you can't and we'll
find out more from David Horowitz who is
that would you say Amy Goodman your your
ideological opposite at this point well
I haven't read much of his stuff so I
have to study up to find out Leonardtown
Marilyn on the moderate line for Amy
Goodman good morning
yeah Brian this is a ray Ross my son was
in an accident yesterday in Kosovo and
he's in severe condition he's in the ICU
'not in a German hospital we just talked
to him on a telephone about 15 minutes
ago you know it's I follow the c-span
and and I guess I'm a political junkie
and
and we're independent voters but when
you start having something like this
happen to you and it's your son and it's
you start looking at cause and effects
you start to wonder what would happen if
the Kosovo's had been armed like we were
whenever we got our independence 200
some years ago we were a little small
nation nobody helped us out and we took
the biggest nation in the world on and
because we had the arms I wonder if the
Kosovo's had the arms and were armed if
I my wife and I'd be sitting here right
now worrying about whether my son's
gonna make it let's go through a couple
things first of all how old is your son
I 29 years old and were how was he hurt
there was a way understand that he was
in a Humvee on a real small road over in
Kosovo and the 18-wheeler pulled out
from the other lane to pass some cars
and that it pulled out directly in front
of him and he swerved to the right and
the 18 wheeler slammed into him and
crushed his pelvic and hip bone and I
guess put a bunch of bones through his
bladder and things like that on the
inside and and when did you first find
out about it yesterday afternoon they
called from the Army casualty center in
Washington DC and and when you talk to
him what did he tell you well he was he
was pretty well doped up we called a
German hospital we tried to get some
information through the army and it just
their system just broke down so I called
directly to Germany and got the
information that I needed and called
directly to the hospital and the
hospital that we were talking to the
people they didn't understand us and
then we finally mentioned his name and
they put us directly to the ICU and we
were talking to him directly but he was
he was all doped up he didn't even know
he was in an accent anybody anybody else
then they Humvee with him yes there was
a sergeant by the way we understand it
because he turned to the right to get
out of the way the truck the truck
smashed into his side of that I'm being
there was a staff sergeant thinking
there with him and he was hooking up and
the way we understand it the driver of
the 18-wheeler is okay too
was driving the 18-wheeler my son oh I
don't know the way don't think we earned
this understood was that the the
18-wheeler was an albanian truck are you
going to see him over there I don't know
that the everything's up in the air
right now we don't know you know we're
just waiting he's still he's in the
operating room as we were talking okay
thank you for sharing that with us this
morning
Amy Goodman Wow best wishes this is
that's just painful to hear that
personal story let's go to Atlanta
Georgia next on the conservative line
good morning morning Brian a couple
comments about health care system in
this country yeah Thomas Jefferson once
said you know if you expected people to
be ignorant and free you expect what
never was and will never be I heard a
very alarming statistic two other day
and I've heard this several times before
that yeah 100,000 people died last year
in this country alone from the side
effects from prescription medications
you know I me personally I've taken much
responsibility and control of my own
health and and geared it towards
prevention and alternative medicine I
think people in this country need to
take more responsibility for their own
health and quit you know depending so
much on the medical industry it is
really alarming how you know you know I
think the old saying an ounce of
prevention is worth a pound of cure the
pharmaceutical and the medical industry
in this country is much much devalued
the worth of prevention because the
bottom line isn't met when you're not
focusing on prevention so much that's a
very important point that you raise and
alternative health care should be much
more incorporated into health care plans
so that people could go to alternative
health practitioners that prevention
would be as valued as you know dealing
with crisis medicine next call we'll go
to Norfolk Virginia good morning on the
moderate line good morning how you doing
fine welcome yes some call this morning
reverence to the east to Murray's topic
that miss Goodman brought up I find it
almost hypocritical that she stays these
figures that tens of thousands of
temari's have been killed
they haven't been no mass graves
uncovered
there hasn't been no evidence of this
has happened at all I do not doubt that
the Indonesia's were heavy-handed with
their treatment is to Maurice but I
finally hypocritical for her to sit up
there and complain about the Indonesian
but you actually gives the Serbs a pass
you know let me just explain something
about East Timor I think because I doing
a bill moyers I mean excuse me the
macneil/lehrer Newshour they actually
had this person from the temari's Action
Network broadcasting from the Indonesian
military back saying that all these
tortures were going on you know that's I
find that ridiculous you know they
inflate these numbers in order to invite
international intervention now for her
she has a whole world of interventions
to once United States to be involved in
but then she criticizes others let me
just point out a few things about the
situation team war those numbers are
really not disputed we're talking about
two hundred thousand people and as for
whether they have dug up mass graves
there is a very small peacekeeping force
in there right now
there is almost no forensic team at this
point that has gone in any numbers of
people to start to discover the extent
of the killings over just the past few
weeks not to mention what has gone on
for a quarter of a century but having
been in Timor and speak spoken with some
of the highest levels of the Indonesian
military as well the 200,000 figure is a
figure that almost everyone uses right
now and as far as saying that you were
watching the Lehren news hour you I
think you were talking about watching
Ellen there and who is my colleague boy
went East Timor with a ninety survived
the massacre in 1991 went back in 94 and
while I was just deported a few weeks
ago from Indonesia as I had to try to
cover the East Timor referendum because
I'm on a military blacklist Allen was
able to get in under that blacklist to
defy it and he was taken by Indonesian
military one of the last foreign
journalists in East Timor and he was on
the Lehren news hour against up against
US Secretary of State Madeleine Albright
but one of the most important thing is
that Allen's discovered in his time in
Indonesia and
East Timor over the last four months and
he just testified before Congress the
House Subcommittee on Human Rights this
past Thursday along with shenanigan Isle
the rebel leader of East Timor and Jose
a Ramos Horta the Nobel Peace Prize
winner Alain Aaron has laid out the US
complicity in 80 in Timor right through
this day you know today Secretary of
Defense William Cohen is returning from
Indonesia and he supposedly gave
warranto the general in charge of the
armed forces a very strong message to
get control of the military to stop the
killings in East Timor but there's a
real question about what message he
actually did give Allen exposed in the
Nation magazine just a few weeks ago
that in April just after another
terrible massacre in Timor committed by
the militias in a place called lick ISA
in a church compound where dozens of
people were machete to death that two
days afterwards Admiral Blair who is the
head of the Pacific Command based in
Hawaii met with Wiranto the US
government was saying he was telling
moranto shut the militias down in fact
what he was doing this according to Alan
Aaron who got memos confidential memos
and cables of these meetings what he was
doing was inviting Wiranto to Hawaii and
offering saying that even more military
aid would come through to the Indonesian
military so we really have to find out
much more uncover not only the mass
graves in East Timor which is critical
which will lead to war crimes tribunals
etc but also completely unearth the US
military relationship to this day with
the brutal Indonesian military Augusta
Georgia for Amy Goodman go ahead please
yes yes I heard the comments on Kosovo
and the bombing and that really I just
found what I thought about but but what
I want to point out was that that was
civilian leadership that puts the
military in to do the bombing in Kosovo
I think you've either taken a poll among
the military we didn't feel we should be
there but what I called about was the
health care issue retirees were promised
health care and was the contractual
agreement really and and they were
I too by the Department of Defense and
never received the health care that was
promised now these are people that by
and large over a million of them are our
drunk retirement pay below the national
poverty level they're drawing retirement
pay about thirteen thousand a year and
the property level 16,000 and if there's
any military Listening out there
congressman Ronnie shows and congressman
Norwood of Georgia have introduced a
bill HR 2960 six to restore the broken
promise of health care to our military
and it's time to start burning up the
phone lines and the email thanks color
Gustav let's go I mean their license in
Kentucky next for Amy Goodman good
morning good morning c-span good morning
miss Goodman yes ma'am I'm calling about
the health care honestly I really
believe that they did all this backward
even from the start do you you have the
you have the upper class of course which
can afford five six seven hundred a
month for good health care now you know
this is true now I met you have the the
what would you call the middle class
poorer they can't afford it at all
and then you have you know welfare
recipients uh a completely poor that the
government provides some kind of health
care form so you have this gap right in
the middle of this working poor that
that just I'm one of them I mean I was
at a job I had insurance la-dee-da and
the job changed now I was in two or
three other jobs that didn't provide it
and I'm 48 years old I called and asked
two or three insurance companies here in
Kentucky were having a problem with the
insurance so the Democrats ran all the
insurance companies out of Kentucky and
they wanted three hundred and eighty
dollars a month and it was a and you
could get cheaper right but it didn't it
wasn't even really insurance I mean you
know you get insurance but it's not
insurance because you got to pay almost
half of it so that's not Insurance makes
a very good case for universal health
care and you're right I mean we should
have health care for everyone in this
country it shouldn't be based whether a
person lives or dies should not be based
on how am I
money they make or they've inherited
from their family should be a right
where are you calling from caller you're
on the air
hello hello caller are you there let's
go to the next call where are you
calling from please we're in California
and San Bernardino you're on the air
what would you like to say to any
Goodman Annie this is about health care
I'm miss my TV chill out no you're done
fine just keep going okay I'm laying in
a hospital bed I'm dying of cancer and
I'm on Social Security with a managed
care that goes with it and it doesn't
begin to pay my bills I am supposed to
be taking a certain kind of medication I
can't even go to my own ecologist
anymore now I've worked since I was 18
years old
sixty-seven years old now and I'm dying
I'm dying because this country can't see
they were clear to take care of us the
elderly people I'm you know I shouldn't
be elderly but I've been fighting this
all this time who is paying for your
hospitalization right now the only
hospitalization I'm not a hospital bed
at home or at home I'm sorry I thought
you were nobody paying for it they pay I
have a managed care and they pay for
what they did well excuse my language
but what they want to pay for and they
have a real cute face not medically
necessary that's what they told me for
10 years until they finally threatened
to sue them and they did a bone scan lo
and behold all this stuff that they said
was a functional pain was bone cancer
that had spread from breast cancer that
I had in 1970 and I'm not getting any
help there's no help my brother says go
to the doctor I said why all they're
gonna do is give me a pill tell me to go
home how long have you been
in your hospital bed in your home five
years well one of the points that you
raised first of all I'm very sorry that
you have been in bed for that many years
and that you've been suffering and don't
have that kind of support that you need
but one of the bills the Dingell bill
that's being considered in the house
right now one of the major issues and
you in California probably know about
this the right to sue when HMOs feel
that they will be sued because they've
denied health care that's a time when
they will probably be more accountable
and that's one of the issues that's
raised in this health bill is that you
can sue your HMO in a state court next
called Portland Oregon for Amy Goodman
of Pacifica Radio she's got 15 minutes
with us left go ahead please yeah I have
two questions one is about NFS m200 its
do of study for population and national
security done by the Rockefeller
Commission that was passed through the
UN that was promoting one two bit older
than 90 years of age and other than John
Adams he's our oldest was it it was put
through by Kissinger but in the third
world countries now and in sex education
in the schools you know promoting
promiscuity why putting Planned
Parenthood is the same so you kind of
spur on the sexually transmitted
diseases but it also included such you
know private funding for like the
Rockefeller Institute for studies on
infertility which means you know this
racist thing where you want to eliminate
the undesirables you know to abortion
and birth control pills but you know
there's a certain class you know that
have six kids of their own like the
Rockefellers that want these to research
infertility also so is Pacifica ever
going to look into these things that
oh ho I might let you go and let them
not to know you're with with what you're
talking about that in in the United
Nations a car referred to I'm glad that
Pacific is back on the air were you off
well the station the first Pacifica
station founded 50 years ago KPFA was
shuttered up for two weeks and a dispute
with management and fortunately now
they're on the air the big concern is
whether the Pacifica Management would
sell any of the pacifica stations they
were concerned that KPFA would be sold
to the station I work at at WBAI it's an
ongoing struggle WBA is located where
WBA is based in New York and the kpf a
based in Berkeley California that was
the first station that was founded in
1949 as part of this non-commercial
Network the idea of an independent media
network in this country that takes no
funding from corporations Herbert Hoover
died at the Waldorf Astoria in New York
City he lived to be a little bit older
than 90 years of age and other than john
adams he's our oldest was our oldest
living president we're gonna feature the
31st president and our special and one
hour from West Branch Iowa not too far
away from Iowa City Richard Norton Smith
Tim Walsh our two guests are two prime
guests on that program two hours and a
half of questions about Herbert Hoover
who was the 31st president in 1928 he
was elected and then the Depression came
in 29 for those of you who don't
remember that although I was not here
either
Detroit Michigan here next morning I'm
just wondering how is the United States
and the people reacting so why aren't we
bombing the Russians for what they're
doing in Chechnya it's a similar
situation that's happened in Yugoslavia
why aren't we bombing the Indonesian for
what they did
enesta more the commoner explained to me
who is in control of the decisions made
that one country is okay to bomb one
country is not what are they doing
impossible presently except
walking around with their guns not
protecting the Serbs not protecting the
people who left there not having safe
passage for the people who do want to
return to their home and throwing
grenades which is the very thing they
did and thought I of all when they and I
when the war broke out and the whole
world learned that the marketplace was
bombed it was bombed by their own Muslim
people such as what they did the past
week
and cost of up oh yeah please Amy I know
you I've heard you before explain to me
what is the difference between Indonesia
Russia that you you biggest country a
most powerful country can choose its
friends and its enemies according to the
capitalism and where they have their
interests Thanks
the US isn't bombing Indonesia because
it's a close ally in fact the United
States in order to end the killing and
the steam war doesn't have to send in
troops just has to stop supporting the
Indonesian military that's doing the
killing and that's often the case in
different countries in the world but I
also wanted to go back to a story that's
in the Los Angeles Times today I just
actually came back from Fresno where I
gave a talk at a radio station that runs
Democracy Now KF CF a community radio
station there and it's a story on page
three by mark a rax of Los Angeles Times
stakes high as prison guards go on trial
and this is a very significant case and
the case begins today and it says that
Corcoran State Prison may be known as
America's deadliest lock up a place
notorious for its own brand of inmate
punishment but among towns folk in this
conservative form built it's just
another dependable employer down the
street but what this case is about is
for prison guards who are accused of
putting a prisoner who is a low-level
gang member 120 pounds named Eddie
Dillard in March 1993 into the cell of a
serial rapist who is more than twice
Eddie Dillard's wait Wayne Robertson to
punish this young Eddie Dillard for an
infraction of the rules he was kept in
that cell for several days as he was
repeatedly raped and this is one of the
only times we see in California that
prison guards are being put on trial I
don't know how much national attention
it's going to get but it certainly
deserves it
we know about Corcoran because of some
brave prison guards that did come
forward in the past to talk about the
kind of atrocities that went on in the
prisons the only thing you could you
could describe it as and particularly
the shoe the security housing unit where
guards would set up prisoners to fight
put the enemies together gang members
who were enemies in a tiny yard they
would fight and then the prisoners the
guards would shoot them killing a number
of these prisoners and then you have the
rape of Eddie Dillard and this after
many years is coming to trial and it's
coming to trial because of a another
brave prison guard who finally after
many years and he was part of this whole
situation
Roscoe Pondexter and after he was kicked
out of Corcoran came forward and said in
fact Eddie Dillard was punished by the
guards and put in a Cell with a known
rapist so this is definitely a trial to
watch Gaithersburg Maryland for Amy
Goodman you're next hello I came from
Yugoslavia Oh long time ago after his
bombing and I saw a terrible situation I
mean pollution and people are very upset
about this what happened in Yugoslavia
so can you give me any advice how can we
help those people after this political
game how I understand Thanks
well it's a good question on the
pacifica radio is democracy now we do a
regular war and peace report we have a
reporter in Yugoslavia in Belgrade
Jeremy Scahill and these are the issues
we have to deal with as a civilized
nation if we're going to bomb a country
what happens afterwards what happens to
the people there we also have to look at
another area of the
world and that's Iraq where the bombings
continue on an extremely regular basis
and yet very few people are aware that
the US continues to bomb Iraq but the
killings in Iraq are actually the least
of them are caused by us bombs that are
dropping its sanctions against Iraq that
have caused untold number of deaths but
we believe upwards of a million deaths
only recently a congressional delegation
of Staff members went to Iraq to
evaluate the effect of the sanctions
that are just destroying this population
and in fact next week October 15th
weekend at the University of Michigan
Ann Arbor there's going to be a the
first major national conference dealing
with the bombing of Iraq and the
sanctions against Iraq that's being put
on by among other groups the education
for peace and Iraq center here in
Washington DC David Horowitz in about
ten minutes
Tucson Arizona on the conservative line
go ahead please I'm calling in response
to the gentleman who called in about
health care and his major concerns was
he said the American people should be
interested in living a healthy lifestyle
an alternative medicine and no one could
argue with a healthy lifestyle but
alternative medicine has me a little
concerned I honestly do believe there is
no such thing as alternative medicine
there was a beautiful article in New
England Journal of Medicine about six
months ago they discuss there is
medication there is treatment and all of
it should be subjected to the same
intense scrutiny now a few weeks ago I'm
a physician I was driving and I was
listening to a talk radio show on a
Saturday there was a fella talking about
oregano well and he said oregano well
with your your acne fine then he said if
you have asthma you should rub oregano
oil on your chest and throw away your
inhaler
throw away your corticosteroids inhalers
because they caused renal suppression
and will kill you well god forbid there
was an asthmatic who was listening to
that and threw away his corticosteroid
inhaler my concern is I turn the
television on and I see ads for weight
loss by using this protect your joints
by using this and I really do think that
the Food and Drug Administration or
someone should get more involved the
answer the alternative medicine is that
people are smart enough I hate to tell
you they really aren't hey can I ask you
a question because it's I've been
hearing these ads lately about is it
kite all is it kite all they advertise
something about if you take this you can
you don't have to you can eat all you
want to eat and you don't ever have to
worry about it because it'll eat away at
the fat yeah I suspect really what that
is is a chelating agent bonding lipid
and I don't know would you go there I
mean was is that something that would
work I don't know that's the problem
okay I'm gonna let you go thanks for the
point I just I mean alternative medicine
has to be taken very seriously precisely
for the reasons this doctor says is that
if it's taken seriously then it will
have the same kind of scrutiny when you
have the powerhouses for example the
American Medical Association that is
just a tremendous lobby in Washington
it's not because some form of
alternative medicine doesn't work that
it's not dealt with in this country it's
simply because they see it as a threat
to standard medical care well two-thirds
of the people in this country turn to
some form of alternative medicine we
have to take it seriously it should be
seriously regulated but we have a lot to
look at in the world of other forms of
medicine particularly Eastern medicine
Port Angeles Washington for Amy Goodman
good morning yes good morning this is
Susan Stricker hi hi I'm talking about
health care and our federal government
and how when we put ourselves out there
for the federal government as well as
for the people and become injured our
federal government seems to kind of let
us go ahead and be disabled regardless
of our feelings or our futures or family
or or any kind of health care besides
that initial injury and I would like to
find someone who could represent all
Americans who have come to Mike my
concern is with my medical problem which
I know a lot of people have is called
RSD and it's excruciating ly painful
I've had this since 93 what is it
RSD it's very painful it's called reflex
sympathy dystrophy and the doctors don't
even understand what it is they don't
know how to treat it therefore they
leave us suffering and going crippled
and the government expects us to go back
to work what do you think about our
principle point about the government not
giving the kind of care that she thinks
to I mean I think so many of the viewers
who are calling in this morning it just
goes to this one major point is we need
universal health care in this country we
need some form of health care that where
everyone can be covered and people don't
feel left out whether you're poor
whether you're middle class health care
is exorbitant and millions of Americans
tens of millions of Americans don't have
it this would be the last call for Amy
Goodman from Pike County Kentucky go
ahead please good morning thank you so
much for c-span welcome I have two
comments to make on East Timor I first
heard about it on the 700 club months
and months before all this came out in
the news that there is a religious
aspect to it and that there is also a
corporate aspect to it because many of
the people who've been imprisoned had
been forced to labor and for ultimately
their people doing business with the
United States I will hang up in Alderson
do well thanks for your call
I would say it is not a religious battle
although East Timor is a Catholic
country but on the issue of corporate
investment yes we have to take that very
seriously none in East Timor but in
Indonesia and why the u.s. is so closely
allied with Indonesia you've got the
large sneaker companies Reebok and Naik
and those women and girls that work in
those plants for two and three dollars a
day know that the same guns there was us
m16s that are trained on the east to
Murray's and killing them or just
outside the plant gates in Indonesia and
that if they dare to organize for better
wages that they face the same kind of
fate so that is very serious not to
mention AT&T General Electric etc yes
unfortunately the way things work in
Indonesia is the reason that
corporations like to invest there is
because it is a quote secure environment
a safe environment which means it is
highly repressive as we say goodbye to
Amy Goodman pass this on to you only
because the caller reminded me of this
piece called up and his son had been
injured in that Humvee accident over in
Kosovo is that it's a kind of a non
sequitur but those of you who watch this
network and saw booknotes with Robert
Hughes who's the art critic of Time
magazine he wrote the history of
American art in deaths throat is the
title of this he wrote it subsequent to
a May automobile accident over on
Australia where he is from originally he
was banged up so badly was in a coma for
one month and you can see a picture of
him right here and he talks about he
says my catalog of trauma turned out to
be a long one below the right knee the
tibia and fibula shattered into a half a
dozen pieces the right femur broken the
ball joint at the hip damaged the elbow
of the right arm crushed several ribs
snapped their sharp ends driven into the
lungs collarbone and sternum busted what
saved me was the merest fluke apart from
punctured lungs if you picturesque cuts
and some bruising to my liver and heart
the damage was all skeletal not soft
tissue my brain was intact did on my
high spine guts and Generals it could
easily have been otherwise and in the
weeks since I have sometimes thought how
wildly irrationally lucky I was to be
spared Robert Hughes
thank you Amy Goodman a native of
Bayshore New York when do we hear you
again on the radio well this morning at
nine o'clock or whenever the station's
run it thanks for joining thanks for
joining us David Horowitz in a couple of
minutes